E aí
G1
o
ar Boa tarde
Seu Paulo Silva sou professor da escola
secundária Inês de Castro Alcobaça e
cumprindo uma tradição de vários
milênios começado essa manhã vou dizer
que o que é que me de Alcobaça
liga-me o facto de ter concorrido para
aqui há
22 anos e ter ficado Ainda bem E liga-me
também o fato de que fui alimentado com
pão de Alcobaça o meu pai era frente no
Cartaxo e trazia pão de Alcobaça
continha postar vidros Alcobaça para
vender no ribatejo
ah e também me liga o facto de terem os
os meus 67 anos e ter vindo Alcobaça em
visita familiar e ter entrado pelas ruas
pela rua das portas de fora e ter visto
gostei frente e uma imagem que fica
ficou comigo ver o mosteiro e o impacto
visual do Mistério que os meus seios
atende 18 volta isso e que ele ficou
marcado
mostra dia eu que iria mais tarde
residir e trabalhar em Alcobaça e Com
muito gosto
ah ah
eu vim preparado com tecnologias de
ponta para o com alguma coisa para para
dizer ah
eu não vou falar sobre histórias mostrar
a gente conhece a
Como está o
e pode ser uma duas coisas
é algo que nos transforma a vida e já
vou já vou dar algumas ideias como ou
uma acusação
E porque é que não fizeste aquilo que eu
estaria a pedir fizesses o patrimônio é
ou uma maldição no caso de estar a cair
e não haver dinheiro para o recuperar ou
uma oportunidade
se recuperar e para fazer dele algo vivo
e de interesse para a comunidade o
último nesse isso a prosseguir só
em material não tem assim grande grande
coisa que se Diga não à educação para
dar valor ao patrimônio e ele não vai
ser valorizado vai ser sempre pedras
lembremos que em Alcobaça como em outros
sítios do país as pedras do Castelo
serviram para fazer casas particulares
numa altura em que o patrimônio não era
não era valorizado mas o patrimônio pode
ser valorizado e pode ser uma mais-valia
para a comunidade é preciso
ver que qualquer momento é monumento
porque foi uma solução do Passado no
passado ele foi uma solução para alguma
coisa
o e este mosteiro foi uma solução para
um problema que envia
envia 148 149 150 km como povoar
defender e desenvolver a zona do centro
do país acabado de conquistar por Dom
Afonso vermelho Afonso Henriques como é
vulgarmente conhecido e ele sorveu a
coisa de uma maneira muito simples
entregou-a a zona do Centro litoral do
país a quem sabe a quem sabe desenvolver
e o mosteiro era o centro de uma ideia
de desenvolvimento integrado e
abrangente que povoou que desenvolveu
que ensinou que
e
orou oratórios mas também trabalhou
Laboratórios Portanto o mosteiro foi uma
solução não tem que ser um problema acho
que não é mas pode ser um desperdício
desperdício e acho que está a ser
desperdiçado e essa visão que eu queria
contrariar hoje entregar o mosteiro um
todo desenvolvimento
e por isso para isso é preciso algumas
ideias Libertadores ideias libertadoras
não se entendem que os clubes tiveram
que ir mais além e
libertamos do passado recente em termos
de mentalidade em termos de que somos
como país a
Primeira ideia e Libertadora podes tocar
no patrimônio patrimônio é pa tocar o
patrimônio né pra ficar estático e não é
para limpar de 50 em 50 anos e olha a
todos assim ah que bonitinho está o
patrimônio é para tocar é para viver é
para sentir se alguém de vez em quando
lá faz um grafite e por fora é
condenável preferenciais Mas isso não é
razão para fechar uma aula inteira no
todos aqui isso aconteceu em Alcobaça
estou dizer que é uma é um exemplo do
que pode acontecer a o patrimônio é para
ser vivido é para entrar para sair para
tocar para
fazer lá um hotel de Charme Como está a
ser feito e muito bem em Alcobaça e
muito mais que é preciso fazer muito
mais do que aquilo que está a ser feito
a segunda ideia Libertadora é deixa a
olhar para o turismo como algo de
inconveniente uma inconveniência que dá
dinheiro
e o turismo é uma inconveniência ganha
nós não suportamos os turistas Mas eles
dão dinheiro portanto temos que viver
com eles o turismo é cada vez mais está
sem modificar o turismo é cada vez mais
exigente cultural as pessoas que viajam
São pessoas que têm que tem aspirações
que sabem o que querem são exigentes e
só regressam se forem bem tratados e o
turismo cultural e eu queria inventar
aqui uma uma expressão
culturismo já existe não é nada disto a
o turismo cultural vai ser o turismo do
futuro e eu que faço um parênteses
depois de resolvidos todos aqueles
problemas que muito bem o João abujamra
salientou) é Um Mundo Ideal que o
projeto aqui a o turismo é público em
movimento público cultural em movimento
é um incessante fluxo de público
cultural não é aquela pessoa que já já
que compram comprou um pano de chita
compra para e vai-se embora tchau se
fosse se fosse maltratado também nunca
mais vou ver porque as coisas morrem
aqui não esse turista vai propagar a
notícia e vai dizer ah para vai Alcobaça
que vais ver que aquilo é giro e essa é
a melhor maneira de
propagar uma imagem a terceira ideia
Libertadora é de que a cultura pode algo
a cultura pode dar lucro a cultura não
tem que viver de subsídios a cultura não
tem que andar a pé inchar a cultura não
tem que andar a a a
desaparecer quando o orçamento de estado
é de vacas magras e a a cultura é algo
que pode afirmar-se por si própria e
pode dar lucro e pode ter pode e deve
ter E pode-se e deve-se ter uma vida
digna com base na cultura e no
espetáculo e espectáculo cultural Não há
razão nenhuma para que a cultura seja
subsídio ao dependente
e a quarta ideia Libertadora que eu
queria dizer é que
bom frente Cristo subsídio-dependência
Já ouvi dizer às vezes quando falava com
pessoas aqui de Alcobaça e Alcobaça não
é diferente dos outros locais ai tem
razão e tal e o até até arriscava mas se
houvesse um subsídio
ou subsídio essa ideia de que somente o
subsídio é o risco eu contra mim falo eu
sou um funcionário público para o bem ou
para o mal é com muita honra e o ser mas
de facto há uma mentalidade é pa deixar
não arriscar deixa cá não riscar e essa
mentalidade tem que ser modificada ter
que passar para o deixa cá arriscar e
claro pronto ninguém vai arriscar pondo
em risco podem risco aquilo que é
fundamental a sua subsistência da
família e por fora mas se houver uma
margem de uma margem razoável para
arriscar a isso deve ser a cultura
também deve ser risco por também deve
ser um ato de
imersão individual de responsabilidade
individual e não pode e se eu tinha
alguma coisa para dizer em termos
culturais não posso deixar de dizer
apenas porque não há subsídio
é bom o turismo não é de massas o
turismo é cada vez mais algo que deve
ser deve ser visto como um público em
potência e
ele está sentado na Esplanada à frente
do mosteiro Que há uns anos atrás e ver
um senhor que nunca conheci pessoalmente
vestido de Dom Pedro o rei a a frente do
mosteiro ia fazer a fazer pela vida e
ouvir as críticas as pessoas À Volta nas
cadeiras da das esplanadas leva aquele
aquela figura e tal cheguei meu vestido
normal parece um rei não sei o que dizer
e
e eu não ligava para essas crianças eu
fiz a mal vestido podia ser faz mal
caracterizado a que podia estar muito
mal feito mas Ele olhou para o mosteiro
e viu uma oportunidade ele investiu nem
vestiu muito porque ela com sapatilhas e
Dom Pedro não caçava Nick mas investiu
alguma coisa isso muito deu a cara deu a
cara em termos empresariais por uma
atitude cultural e ele tirou muitas
fotografias já estaremos Facebook já
está em escolher o cara pelo mundo
inteiro por toda a gente quis tirou ser
fios com João Pedro eu sempre achei que
lhe faltava uma Dona Inês Mas isso é
outra questão
e a essa atitude essa atitude olhar para
o mosteiro como uma oportunidade e o
mistério é uma pedra por lá é um
diamante por lapidar está vazio e vazio
em mais sentido do que um isso não é uma
crítica a ninguém nem a instituições é
apenas a conta de aquilo que eu acho que
é a constatação de um fato
o mosteiro devia ser
um polo experimental para aquilo que eu
chamo a experiência Alcobaça imagine o
senhor Suzuki que é o nome japonês muito
pouco conhecido e ele está no Japão a no
seu computador é programar uma viagem a
Portugal e o Japão já agora ele história
de Pedro e Inês é logo a seguir a Romeu
e Julieta a história de amor mais
conhecida e mais trabalhada e esse meu
Suzuki o
pleito foi internet quando cá chega
Lisboa transferir para Alcobaça e quando
chega a Alcobaça ele é a e nos sites
acho que eu quis fazer ele em Alcobaça é
recebido por guias turísticos
especializados que o vão levar ao
alojamento e que eu vou levar aos
diferentes sítios de interesse a da
Alcobaça chegamos à espera que este
envolve hotelaria este envolve
informática este envolve a toda uma
criação de emprego que a volta porque os
jovens alcobaças em Alcobaça porque não
ficam em Alcobaça que é que os jovens
não onde ficar em Alcobaça e criar
calças emprego e depois o seu Suzuki EA
sua mulher vão para o mosteiro e vão
assistir as dramatizações a projeções a
peças de teatro história de Pedro e Inês
a história de Portugal em 90 minutos
o teatro dramaturgia Artes música
medieval academia de Alcobaça escolas
profissionais da escola Inês de Castro
escolas profissionais podem ser chamadas
a criar programas que simultaneamente
estimula turismo e sejam avaliativos
para os seus alunos
bom depois não estar antes uma em mente
da pedra ideias pode ser um hambúrguer
Mas é muita Pedro e Inês e os turistas
gostam daquilo É bom que não seja um
hambúrguer é bom que seja comida
portuguesa tradicional mas isso vai
obrigar-nos a pesquisar a nossa
gastronomia para o turismo de qualidade
é um desafio a nossa cultura é Um
Desafio cultural estão desafiados eles
querem conhecer e mas para que nós
digamos alguma coisa é preciso que
começamos a nossa cultura portanto é Um
Desafio cultural
depois palestras depois transferes de
Nazaré para Alcobaça os teus são o tempo
está encoberto ainda não fizeram aos
horas podem da digestão para
em
13 caráter Alcobaça e vem conhecer vem
ter a sua experiência bom da hotelaria
ao comércio à indústria
mãos por um dia quero ser mãos por um
dia então o turista veste um hábito que
eu paga veste um hábito e vai passear no
campo vai fazer o seu pote
e a
o seu licor resumo de seja a variante
mais mais requisitada e o turista vai
sentir-se integrado naquilo que seja uma
experiência de Alcobaça é porque não
transformar o que basta uma escola
internacional uma universidade deverão
trazer cá professores trazer cá fazer
fazer cursos livres para turistas onde
aprendem sobre a cultura portuguesa a
nós vamos achamos a Portugal alguma
coisa que fizemos foi ir Alcobaça e
aprender sobre a cultura Portuguesa ao
cobrar uma somos tem tanto espaço livre
para fazer isso tudo chamar Professor
estrangeiros chama pessoas portugueses
por os nossos Miúdos das escolas
profissionais a fazer isso uma escola de
verão um rabo empresa em Empresarial a
para super provar que sai
mostrar para para fazer nascer starters
in
bom e que essa alguns unicórnios a no no
campo do Turismo no campo do Turismo
cultural no campo do Turismo e do
Turismo de qualidade
o turismo vai ser uma das vai ser o
importante para Portugal nos próximos
tempos Isto pode ser interligado com
tomar gosto de tomar com
a batalha com Santarém a ver aqui um um
circuito
esta visão que eu tenho para Alcobaça de
fazer com que a criar uma experiência
Alcobaça que faça com que o turista
regresse faz com que o turista de vanha
faça com que turista recomendo E cria
emprego em Alcobaça fixo jovens de
Alcobaça criou
uma dinâmica cultural a fatos passa pela
criação de uma agência turística em
Alcobaça que sem menosprezo do que já
existe a Possa dinamizar possa fazer com
que turista aqui o cliente projetos que
postou entregas a particulares por
exemplo seja como for a esta dinâmica de
Alcobaça fazer com que Alcobaça seja só
para terminar o Fim de semana passado
fui eu fiz um Passeio Familiar a
alentejo pelo norte do alentejo e passei
pela terra que nesse alentejo já é
ribatejo Crush e vi lá coruche capital
mundial da cortiça
e eu pensei se estes homens estão a
celebrar a cortiça em coruche e muito
bem
em Alcobaça tem muito mais ainda para
Celebrar Muito obrigado a
E aí